Aujourd'hui, il fait plus frais et il y a du vent.
Je me suis installé dans l'atelier.
Les éoliennes tournent à plein régime.
Le vent c'est une circulation d'air d'une zone de haute pression vers une zone de basse pression.
L'air qui nous entoure, chauffé par le soleil, se dilate.
Les molécules qui le composent
s'écartent les unes des autres.
Il est moins dense que l'air froid
et sa pression est plus faible.
A volume égal, l'air chaud est plus léger que l'air froid.
il s'élève dans l'atmosphère et
comme la nature cherche toujours l'équilibre,
l'air froid prend sa place en allant toujours
d'une zone où la pression est plus forte
vers une zone où la pression est plus faible.
C'est ce qui est à l'origine des coups de vent,
et de cette nouvelle "capsule de déconfiné"
en coup de vent !
Allez à demain et n'oubliez pas :
nous sommes confinés mais on reste en lien
Si vous avez aimé cette vidéo
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleu
J'en réalise une nouvelle chaque jour.
Alors pour ne rater aucune
de ces "capsules de déconfiné",
abonnez-vous et activez la petite cloche.
Merci à toutes et à tous et à demain...